I swear this mountains over there
somewhere morning John going to
Australia
getting on the plane right now I'm in
Denver whereas I still honestly call at
Isengard where those done airports are a
really good time they're like sit and
look at people do you like I know so
much about that person just by glancing
yeah it feels like it takes so little
data for me to put somebody in a
category and then like oh I also kind of
believe that person is a student that
person's a business person that's just a
family with the kids but it's deeper
than that
right cuz I go look at somebody I rely
like you like I know things about that I
think about their politics or I know
things about how they see the world just
bite it like looking at their beer I
can't help but do that right at least
you got think about the fact that you're
doing this is my plane they're gonna put
some food on it put some food on my
plane please autofocus isn't working
which is really that's not good it was
gonna expensive lens I want it to not be
broken I have great news I turned it on
and turned it back up again and it works
man it jacked itself up now it's not now
it's up there didn't expect that to
happen
I mean what's in that thing really
except for just a bunch of pretzels this
makes me want to play Airport simulator
okay it's 5:30 I'm not playing Airport
simulator at an airport plane
this is what the ceiling looks like and
there's my gate and there's Dave's head
hello Dave's head
what's that oh my god this is a
beautiful shot Gracie's got really
excited about the US Open who's Lindsay
Davenport Mystica on the tail end when
Serena and Venus going for anything
she's a tennis player
in the story of my life was getting on
the plane so the word is stay up as late
as you can and then go to sleep and wake
up and it'll be morning in Melbourne so
I power through
[Music]
his movement watch
and I wake up I'll be in the southern
anesthesia state back to bed and when I
woke up pretty much everybody else it
hard to open up so I feel like I might
win I have a great first day in
Melbourne this is my big beautiful view
of the outside of beautiful Melbourne
and there's a lot of beautiful sunlight
coming through and I got this chocolate
bar dono hello beautiful chocolate I'm
sorry and it's got directions to boba
tea from a crash course then we'll see
how this turns out success cash only
more bad news
okay well tomorrow then they rented a
bike this is where it comes in at me
tomorrow this time now for something
that I want to do even though it seems a
little silly
this looks like an OK spot southern
hemisphere
John I'll see you on Tuesday
[Music]
you